un camion immatriculé en Roumanie venant
de Pologne et dont le chauffeur était
moldave qui contient plus d'un
demimillion de paquets de malborau
contrefait les derniersres saisies des
douanes sont colossales en tout 13
tonnes de cigarettes estimées à 6,83
millions d'euros en 2 ans on observe une
augmentation de 125 % des saisis de
cigarettes les Haut- de France
représentent à eux seuls environ 200
tonnes mais alors quelles sont les
raisons derrière les sort de cet immense
trafic d'abord l'augmentation de la
fiscalité sur le tabac elle a rendu le
paquet de cigarettes si cher que les
produits de contrebande ont trouvé en
France un marché tout désigné
l'inflation ensuite qui ne fait
qu'accentuer ce phénomène au marché noir
un paquet coûte 1 à 2 € à fabriquer et
se revend entre 5 et 7 € les usines
clandestines elles pululent en Pologne
en Belgique en Italie et en Espagne même
en France ces ateliers mécanisés
émergent six ont été démantelés depuis
2021 parallèlement les vols de tabac se
multiplient selon la direction générale
des douanes d'ailleurs les émeutes de
cet été après la mort de naë ont été
émaillé d'innombrables effractions en
bande chez des buralistes dans les cités
les cigarettes transitent désormais par
les points de deal car ce phénomène ne
concerne pas que les métropoles villes
moyennes et campagnes sont touchées
résultat le gouvernement met les
bouchées doubles chien renifleur cyber
enquête groupe de lutte antitrafic de
tabac ou encore durcissement des peines
de prison Bery a lancé un plan d'action
2023-2025 car derrière ces trafics
d'apparence anodine il y a de vrais
enjeux de sécurité assure le patron de
la douane de
dunkerk